hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the US Chess Championship
this is round three and we have a nice
game between Ray Robson and abanu Mishra
you guys requested some games by Mishra
as you know he is the youngest
Grandmaster to ever become a Grandmaster
he um overtook Sergey karakin record and
he became a Grandmaster at the age of 12
Years 4 months and 25 days uh and he uh
mentioned on several occasions that he
would very much enjoy becoming the
youngest world champion ion ever as well
uh how how is he doing let's check it
out like I said the first game we're
going to check is against Ray Robson and
this is from round three and then we're
going to check out the game from round
four that is the US championship last
year the winner was Fabiana corana who
is um I'm not going to spoil it uh we're
going to talk about it after we show the
games uh but yeah it's uh an hour and a
half for the first 40 moves and then you
get additional times you I think you get
like 30 minutes for the rest of the game
and there's a 30 seconds increment start
starting from move one so not from move
60 what I with I which I prefer but you
actually get increment from move one uh
so that being said let's check it out so
uh this is a really really Theory packed
the game there are like 20 moves of
known Theory so um we're going to skip
most of the the game so Ray opens with
D4 we have Pawn to D5 C4 C6 going for
the slav defense we have Knight to F3
Knight to F6 and now Knight to C3 we
have e six going for the semi slav uh
formation G3 and D captures and C4 so
nothing new here all been played before
Bishop G2 uh not B5 right away but first
Knight B to D7 uh we have castles and
now Pawn to B5 we have Pawn to E4 and
now Bishop to B7 you could also go for
Pawn to B4 but it's not really anything
spectacular white will play Pawn to E5
and when you move your knight white will
move his Knight so it can be played and
it has been played Bishop to B7 is just
a bit more common so Bishop B7 we have
Pawn to E5 Knight to D5 and now Knight
to G5 if you go Knight E4 black will
just uh move the uh take away the G5
Square from the Knight so here Robson
goes for it right away and now Pawn to
H6 and what do you think Robson played
here he played Knight captures on E6 so
it's a peace sacrifice but a very
well-known one uh for those of you who
are into the semi slab F captures on E6
Queen to H5 with check King to E7 and
now Knight to E4 we have Queen to E8 of
course trying to exchange queens and now
Bishop to G5 with check you now H
captures and G5 is the top move here
everyone plays it but there is one game
uh Anand played it against um uh sorry
Vladimir Kik played it against vishan
Anand Kik had the white pieces here and
in that game after Bishop to G5 check
Anand actually played a a knight uh uh
uh Knight F6 and the game continued by
pretty much getting everything traded
off e captures G captures Bishop
captures Knight captures Knight captures
now defending the queen queen captures
Knight captures and you had the S game
two Bishops against the Knight and
Bishop uh their game ended in a draw but
pretty much all the other games continue
h captures on G5 as does this one here
uh Queen captures on h8 now grabbing The
Rook King to d8 trying to hide your king
and now comes Knight captures on G5 L
Babu had this position against the ding
L and also in 2015 as obviously the uh
the variation was quite popular in 2015
and he played Queen to G8 but he lost
that game interestingly Queen to G8 is
the second uh move uh second or the
third top move recommended by the engine
but obviously not um good enough against
ding so Knight captures on G5 Queen to
E7 now attacking the Knight and queen to
H5 defending we have King to C7 uh and
now there are a couple of games where
Rook 8 to E1 was played but here we have
Queen to G6 and it is now as of move 18
that we have a completely new game so
this is now completely new territory uh
for us but as it would seem not for the
players because here in this position
before uh Queen to G6 I actually allowed
the engine to Crunch the numbers to like
maybe depth 50 and the engine says yeah
just play Queen to G6 play A4 play Rook
A3 play Rook F3 and bring the Rook over
to F7 so that's the engine's plan and
that's the exact plan that Robson went
for so Queen to G6 we have Rook to E8
now you have after also Queen to G6
comes with tempo as you now put pressure
on the E6 Pawn so Rook to E8 and now
Pawn to A4 making room for Rook to A3 uh
and if you go for for Pawn to B4 while
you stop Rook to A3 you do weaken your
position a little bit then the the C uh
file might become problematic and also
the Knight can jump to F7 right away you
can go to to D6 put pressure on C4 so
not the best so after A4 we have King to
B8 and now Rook to A3 preparing the
maneuver that we just discussed Knight
to C7 adding more defense to the E6 Pawn
so now the queen can move and now uh
Rook to F3 we have B captures on A4 and
now Pawn to H4 the pawn now marches
forward Queen to d8 and now Rook to F7
so okay the queen moved but you are
Defending Your Pawn with the Knight and
the Rook so Rook to E7 offering a rook
trade uh and now Rook back to F4 and now
uh of course you uh realize why white
does not want to trade Robson wants to
um uh improve his position as much as
possible and try to get those pawns all
the way up the board G5 and H6 once they
are played uh he should have definite
compensation for the sacrificed material
but here if he just trades down and that
is what Mishra of course is going for
then look at this A4 and C4 pawns if uh
imagine all of all of the pieces just
traded down and we go into a king and
pawn end game what will happen well
Misha will play C3 B captures on C3 and
the a pawn wins the game so of course
you know that if everything gets Trad
off the board and the white king is
still on the king side it's completely
winning for black so that will be his
plan and of course Robson wants to keep
material on the board Rook F4 we have
Queen to E8 offering a queen trade Queen
to H7 now and here you should play
Knight to D5 but uh uh G6 was played in
the game and this sort of allows um Ray
to to win the G6 Pawn he just has to
play Knight to F7 and next pick up the
pawn here point is that black there's no
way for black to do anything if uh
Knight B6 uh Queen captures on G6 now
the Knight comes to B D5 attacks The
Rook here uh Bishop captures on D5 you
will give up your bishop and after he
captures you will play Rook F6 and you
will start advancing your past H Pawn so
that's the best way for white to play
however he played Rook to F7 instead but
now it's different now The Rook can
actually uh move from E7 the Rooks can
get traded off and it's not as potent
even though you will win the G6 Pawn so
Pawn to C5 offers a trade of Bishops and
also threaten C captures on D4 uh we
have Bishop captures on B7 King captures
and now Queen captures on G6 so the past
Pawn has been created and also the past
G Pawn is now available too Rook
captures we have Knight captures and C
captures on D4 now mi Mishra also has a
pass the D pawn queen to E4 with check
nicely connecting with the D4 pawn and
now Knight to D5 we have Knight to D6 uh
also trading Knight for Bishop Bishop
captures Pawn captures and now Queen to
ah guarding the D4 Pawn Rook to D1
attacking the pawn and now defending
with a tactic Knight to E5 and now the
problem is you cannot touch the pawn of
course if Queen captures Knight F3 check
picks up the queen and if Rook captures
you still play Knight F3 check uh you
give up the Knight and then you pick up
the Rook here and you're just up a full
piece yes okay there's the G and H Pawn
but a full piece I mean we already
discussed C3 and the a pawn marches
forward so after Knights to E5 we have
Pawn to D7 uh trading off the past D
Pawn for the past um D4 Pawn uh Knight
captures on D7 Queen captures on D4
Queen captures and Rook captures so now
it's a rook against two knights but now
comes the move that we've discussed but
which move do you think it is feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
abim Manu while I give you a couple of
[Music]
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on not
touching the C pawn and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Pawn to A3 that's the move it maybe
counterintuitive a little bit because
you want to have the outside sorry about
that you want to have the outside pass
Pawn but here it wouldn't work if you
played C3 first then B captures A3 you
can just play Rook to A4 and there's no
good way to defend your Pawn here so
instead Pawn to A3 was played and now B
captures on A3 uh if you go Rook
captures on C4 then just a Capt after
some B2 the Knight covers the B4 Square
the pawn covers the C1 Square so next
move uh black is getting a queen so
after A3 he has to play B captures on A3
Now Pawn to C3 where the C3 Pawn is now
nicely defended by the Knight we have
Rook to D1 Knight to C5 Now Pawn to H5
now of course Ray would also um like to
advance his Pawn as
much you as close to the e h Square as
possible and Mishra has to decide uh
does he have to block that or can he
actually go for the attack and finish
the game right away and he calculates
precisely he plays Knight to D3 of
course the Knight is off limits you're
just going to push the pawn and uh
there's no way for the for the Rook to
defend as the C3 and D1 square squares
are now covered so after Knight D3 H6 uh
Ray starts advancing his pass Pawn C2
Rook to F1 and now Knight to F6 a very
important move guarding the H7 Square G4
and now not just winning The Rook but
first Knight to H7 stop the expansion of
um White's King side pawns King to G2
and now C1 bringing a queen into the
game Rook captures Knight captures and
now Pawn to F4 so of course uh Ray will
still try to advance those pawns and
fight against the Knight but the king
and two knights are just too powerful
King C6 we have King to F3 uh King to D5
um and now Pawn to G5 we have Knight to
f8 Guardian G6 and H7 King to G4 and now
Knight Knight to D3 two knights are
simply too much we have Pawn to F5
captures uh not captures first Knight to
E5 with check King to F4 and now Knight
G to F6 with check well you don't have
to give up the Knight um here abanu just
says that uh he doesn't want to uh you
know it's you might make a mistake here
and this is just you know winning by
force so you don't have to calculate
anything so that's why he played it
captures captures with check King to G4
and now of course King to E4 we have
Pawn to A4 Pawn to a A5 and now forcing
the king uh well first the H H7 King to
E5 and now King to H5 King to F5 and
here we have King to H6 and pawn to E5
and it was in this position un move 56
uh that Ray Robson resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
once you win the Knight King G7 uh E4 is
just winning of course you will win the
Knight captures captures and just Pawn
to E3 if you move the king uh closer
then we pick up the pawn and if you push
the pawn you can also just pick up the
pawn and um next promote your Pawn to a
queen so excellent game with the black
Pieces by abanu Mishra who uh I mean
you've seen how much Theory the the two
of them had gone through even with this
queen to G6 move that Robson prepared
which was the absolute top engine move
and the entire plan was the absolute top
engine plan uh Mishra survives and you
know he ends up um on top so yeah there
there was that that one moment where he
could have maybe um went for uh the move
that we discussed when all once all of
this was played not Rook to F7 but
instead Knight to F7 which would um
allow him to have the the upper hand but
once he missed that it was all abim Manu
so this is game from round three and in
round four Mishra faced none other than
Hans Neiman so we're going to check out
that game as well in this game abanu had
the wi pieces so of course you all know
Hans let's check it out and see what
happened here if he wins this one then
Abby will defin itely be a contender to
to to actually win the tournament so
Pawn to E4 and uh um Hans goes for the
Cilan defense with have Pawn to C5
Knight F3 Knight to C6 and now Bishop to
B5 here I always like to mention B4 my
favorite line for bulletin Blitz you
will win many games if you learn this
line very cool and very few people know
how to play it against black but it's
not great for classical it's like the
the 11th most popular continuation but
people still do play it Bishop to B5 um
the so n medino rosimo attack we have
Pawn to G6 and now castles we have
Bishop to G7 C3 and now Knight to F6 so
that this game also uh fully fully
packed with known Theory Rook to E1 we
have castles and now Pawn to D4 we have
Pawn to D5 by hunt E5 and Knight to E4
again everything been seen before Bishop
captures we have B captures and Bishop
to E3 Queen to B6 now putting pressure
on the B2 pawn and queen to C1 we have
Pawn to C4 h um logs the position and
Knight B to D2 offering a trade of
knights we have Knight captures Knight
captures and now we have Bishop to F5
nicely developing putting the preparing
to put the bishop on D3 we have Pawn to
B3 and now Bishop to D3 with Pawn to H4
and now there are a couple games that
reach this position and I even allowed
the engine to Crunch the numbers also to
depth 50 because I wanted to see how
much the players were um within their
preparation and A5 is a known move here
and A5 is is the to the top move
recommended by the engine but here we
have Pawn to H5 which is not even in the
top three so this is I guess maybe
something hunt came up with over the
board or maybe it's like maybe the
seventh um uh engine suggestion but it's
also just very strong uh so that there
you have it so it is now as of move 15
that we have a completely new game so
Bishop to G5 uh putting pressure on D7
pawn and while you could defend this
with Pawn to E6 you will also as you
plan to C capture here and then Pawn
captures you will free up D4 Square for
the Knight you will weaken these two
squares so for the moment the pawn
should remain on E7 so Rook F to8 we
have B captures on C4 uh D captures on
C4 and now Knight to E4 and this is now
a great knight preparing to become a
monster Knight with Knight C5 and also
if this gets played then Black's
position just gets destroyed so it's
better just U Goble up that Knight
Bishop captured even though your Bishop
is strong in D3 the potential of this
Knight to become even more powerful is
definitely there so it's uh it's good
that he traded it Bishop captures Rook
captures and now Rook a to B8 gaining
control over the B file so Rook E2 not
allowing um uh the queen to come to B2
and we have Queen to A5 now honing in on
White's weaknesses D A2 and C3 pawns
Queen to E3 and now Queen to D5 nicely
centralizing the queen Rook a to E1
tripling up on the E file and queen to
E6 now H we have Queen to E4 ABI Manu
also centralizes his Queen and now Rook
to
B5 uh Pawn to F3 as it's uh Pawn to F3
is a useful move but it's very hard to
find a a way how to actually make
progress in this position so Queen to D5
un soers a queen trade he would very
much like to UND double his pawns but
abanu of course declines this queen to
F4 and now C5 yeah you have a doubled
Pawn abanu has a beautiful Pawn Center
here it's time to trade the a pawn for
pawn and and uh weaken it a little bit
and while you would definitely enjoy uh
keeping the center like let's say you
play something like King to F1 uh and
allow this then once the ru comes to C8
you will have to fight against this past
C Pawn maybe a little bit too much to
allow black so instead D captures and C5
was played Queen captures on C5 with
check and queen to E3 now Abby offers a
queen trade Rook to C8 and now we have
Queen captures and C5 Rook C captures
and C5 so now putting pressure on this
E5 pawn and the problem is if you play
F4 here believe it or not this is
already lost for white you you put your
Bishop out of the game and there's just
no good way to get it back into the game
so um here abanu figures out a different
plan he plays Pawn to E6 and now he will
uh Ru enhance his Pawn structure and
also just go into a very nice end game
so F captures an E6 we have Rook to E4
now and Rook Bishop captures on C3 but
now you start recollecting Rook Rook to
C1 attacks the bishop Bishop to E5 and
Rook e captures on C4 we have captures
captures and Bishop to G3 now well
controlling F2 and H2 now preparing Rook
to B1 with check but of course uh abim
Manu will not allow that King to F1 and
now Rook to B1 with check and now uh in
order to really uh really play this to
the fullest you have to play King to E2
it's an ugly move uh to to to play but
you have to play it and this I will just
show it because it's the best move Rook
to be you check King D3 now you collect
on A2 now you collect on E7 and now Rook
captures on G2 so you are down two pawns
but you will win at least one of them no
you will win one of them back at least
and then probably more for example if
Rook to A4 you put pressure on this Pawn
Rook H2 uh puts pressure on this Pawn
but you are defending it for the moment
so you don't really have to worry best
just improve your position Bishop G5 and
if Bishop F2 guarding this pawn it
doesn't matter you will go after this
Pawn you will you will win one of them
and if um King to F7 just Rook to F4
check and you have a draw the king now
has to move back King to G7 or or King
back to G8 you will repeat Rook to E4
because if you go up the board then Rook
to F6 will again go after D6 and G6
pawns and this is where you find
sufficient counterplay to actually hold
this position but Bishop to C1 was
played and this allows Hans to uh grab
too much of the position Rook to A1
attacks the pawn Here pawn to A4 and now
Bishop captures an H4 now if Rook
captures Rook captures on C1 and you're
just going to be down too many Pawns in
a in a rook and pawn end game so King to
E2 Rook to A2 with check Bishop to D2
and now Bishop to G5 threatening to win
the bishop here so Pawn to F4 you have
to play it and now Bishop back to H6 we
have King to D3 and now Pawn to E5 again
uh F captures an E5 impossible because
of Rook captures on D2 so Pawn to G3 we
have e captures G captures and now again
Pawn to E5 so nicely getting rid of the
doubled E Pawn uh Rook to C8 with check
King to F7 and now Rook to C7 with check
we have King to E6 and Rook captures on
A7 keeping the past a pawn e captures on
F4 and now Rook to A6 with check the
King has to defend on G6 so Rook to A5
with check King to G4 and Rook to A6 we
have Pawn to H4 uh there is no uh uh
there is no stopping the pawns now you
are up two pawns and you're well
uh White pieces are just too far away to
to stop them Rook captures on G6 played
with check but it doesn't matter Bishop
to G5 we have Bishop to B4 uh sorry not
Bishop to C3 Bishop to B4 even preparing
Bishop to E7 to win the bishop on G5 uh
but hunt shows that it doesn't matter
just Pawn to
F3 uh Bishop to C5 if you go after the
bishop it doesn't matter just Pawn to F2
and the pawn is now Unstoppable the king
cannot cross the second rank uh and once
you capture just King to F4 and now you
don't have a rook to G1 you don't have
King to F Rook to F5 F1 will Queen on
the next move and that's pretty much it
similar is what happened in the game
Bishop to C5 was played uh but doesn't
really matter now comes Pawn to H3
Bishop to E7 and now Pawn to F2 so uh
with the inclusion of one move Rook
captures on G5 King to F4 and he was in
this position on move 53 that abanu
Mishra resigned the game and a very nice
victory for H nean in round four of this
year's us Chess Championship so uh abanu
had a playable position but you've seen
how uh difficult the position was it was
like every move you could make uh not
one but 10 mistakes so both for him and
H so was a really complicated position
and uh hunt emerged Victorious from it
and these are the standings um let me
just load this up after four runs have
been played so the leader is last year's
winner Fabiano corana uh if you guys
want to see any of his games do also use
asht suggestion I might even show them H
even if you guys don't ask me anything
but probably after fifth round is played
then in second place sharing with two
and a half out of four Hans nean and Sam
shankland and abanu Mishra uh two two
and a half out of four two two out of
four Dominguez Perez lenier Wesley saw
Samuel Sean Leon arunan with one and a
half points Andrew Tang Jeffrey Shong
Dario SCH and in last place with one uh
point out of four uh Ray Robson although
uh hard to imagine but it's a strong
tournament anyone can beat anyone and uh
it will be interesting what happens in
the end but Fabby you know solid as a
rock as usual we'll see if anyone will
be able to to grab a full point from him
uh so yeah that's the game or rather
those were the games hope you guys
enjoyed that um uh if you have any other
favor like I said do use hasht
suggestion I will do my best to cover
them uh I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to audrius and I would
like to thank Mr hoody guy the brus on
Spotify Petra marinov and an anonymous
person for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and probably I will
show my game from the creation chess
League next um uh so you know stay tuned
for that uh see you soon